today someone said nice meeting you Jim
there are much worse things to be known
as the Jim Halpert from the Opera move
that's kind of one of these when I first
got the office my friends and I went to
a bar and we're talking like season one
and my friends we couldn't get in the
bar and my friends just said just go up
and just say hear from the office and I
said okay so I went up to this bouncer
and I said I'm I'm an actor I'm the guy
on the office and he goes I don't care I
don't think I can successfully really
incorporate all that is Chris Pratt
there's a whole lot of charm there any
kids movie definitely The Lion King
frozen cred in that at Olaf of all
people I'm 92 years old oh I don't even
know how to turn on my phone that's not
you I do know how to turn on my phone
I'm good I don't know how to do email or
Twitter that mean that you get to like
wrestle an actual creature to the ground
I've had a great experience with Hoover
but there have been one or two times
where I feel like I'm in speed racer
which is exciting and terrifying no I
don't think I've watched any episodes
since the show wrapped we always used to
get together to watch the episodes so
there's nothing that fun as getting
together with your whole cast and like
having your arms around each other
eating a couple cheese plates I don't
know if I can recreate that
[Music]
yeah
as an adult you're like checking out get
some fries I mean I'm not gonna eat like
a whole bland colored meal and then you
order it for the your daughter and I've
had my daughter say like I don't want
chicken nuggets and the waitress will
come by a bit shaken up it's and then
they're gone
[Music]